allora ragazzi questo video è
incredibile perché ho fatto fuori quasi
quasi perché è morto uno all'inizio ho
dovuto fare tutto da solo e ho segnato
tanto così da vinci a incredibile dove
metterla per forza ragazzi spero che vi
piaccia morali york
[Musica]
ragazzuoli belli bellissimi la prima
vecchio sono sempre impostore se ci fate
caso non so per quale chiacchiere motivo
adesso va da un'altra parte siamo subito
online che noi a statua fi basket siamo
subito ragazzi stava andando verso
navigation è uscito trovato subito molto
serie nel sistema dell'area che secondo
me è marcia quando parla tanto e lui e
soprattutto quando dice è vero è morta
anche bravo a porta anche fare era prima
cosa che noti appena c'è l'immagine sono
d'accordo con te è il fatto che lui
l'abbia detto a e morta e mimì fatto
sospettare di lui già visto che ero
passato vicino a gas e cera che noi che
sta facendo una tasca quindi credo non
sia stata lei provo che dobbiamo fatta
marcia far fuori subito vedi che ora in
silenzio perché non sanno in che cosa
dire
è lui è lui
ma la minima mike lasciato mi sento
troppo in colpa scusate no ragazzi
assurdo ciao rimasta la sola vice sono
molto contento di tutto questo e quindi
che devo fà sono completamente da solo
ragazzi non ce la farò mai a vincerla ci
provo e ci provo voglio provarci
veramente mercato difficile ci provo
abbiamo una paura incredibile riportata
in via via ora che la fanno perché sono
chiamo calmi e no 1 e marci ho trovato
che noi al di sotto era appena andato in
armi da vedere dove stava la gente ok
però eravamo comunque tutti lì io li ho
marchionne hanno già volta l'ho vista
dell'etica poi sono sono lieto della
spezieria gli skipper e ma siamo la
fontana o caio
in base a cosa non lo so non so ma io
non credo sarà gaglio cipro ve lo giuro
ci provo ma è difficilissimo e
difficilissimo ragazzi perché da solo ma
lasciato subito solo cosa devo fare io
io veramente non so meglio di come fare
sì gente
badoino 21 prende spesso presente niente
ma preso sicuro 100 100
raga l'ho trovato nel corri dove stava
andando da da security che ho finito la
task a cose dell'ossigeno e l'ho trovato
nel corridoio tipo prima di reaktor io
le telecamere prima l'avevo visto io
però poi sono dalle menti ansa quindi
ieri morti fate tasto ma secondo me
perché volendo possiamo fare votazione
mi portate fuori poi sapete lui io non
rischierei race later
ok ma è stata una gran bella tattica
questo caso va detto però non va non ce
la farò mai ragazzi sono da solo sono
completamente da solo magari imposte è
veramente impossibile
cioè se sei da solo dall'inizio non puoi
farci simile ragazzo rivediamo ok però
vedere se riesco ad aspettare un tosto
che magari qualcuno no no man cercare
davvero una signora
la storia è stata che io stavo tornelli
ritrovo aver fatto il reattore
contestiamo si fa vincere ma ero
talmente da solo dalle mappe e basta ma
non solo ero solo da limiterà le faccio
dire che era il posto di rete andata
proprio di sfiga perché io stavo venendo
lì per fare perché per fare l'emergency
meeting per capire chi fosse
effettivamente e poi
e andata guarda se ti avessi chiuso la
porta di capire secondo prima non passa
vengono riportati
mi dispiace solo dall'inizio la partita
è impossibile io questa la linea della
spiaggia di calore dalle telecamere però
mi ha deciso questo vediamo se riesco a
trovarlo ragazzi il modo giusto è andata
bene sono due settimane che non faccio
stata solo quella di un vero lavoratore
adesso mi sento un vero lavoratore basta
questo picks live serve solo al killer
ucciderli nascosto però sono arrivato io
prima quindi si chiude no eccoci qua o
una tasca in di el ex scout ma molassa
da scasso
allora il discorso ragazzi e che adesso
ci conosciamo behrami 60 ormai noi che
giochiamo quindi è molto pi satisfy del
mondo para para il meme del tipo
cordolino ogni volta che succede se
conosciamo talmente bene che ora è
difficile trovare è difficile vincere la
impostore quindi vediamo a parte che
noia che incrocia la gente alla mazza è
proprio difficile vincere da impostore
mini vediamo se riesco a fare una collo
e giusta intanto finisco le tasche e ne
mette che le faccio vedere la mazza
regole ci manca solo quello di mettere
faccio la cisco a incontrare qualcuno
che ammazza no c'era il corpo di marcia
il navigation e stef era tranquillo è
passato davanti e il mango l'area
portata stava per segnare
qualcosa potenziato
io mi fido solo perché mi avresti
uccidere va bene ma quando però è un po
troppo romantico arrivai alla prima così
disparate non lo so non mi fido mai dopo
un grave riprende che per i cari l'airar
ragazzi non mi racconta mai giusta step
ma mai nella vita quindi occhio a step
se mi capita state davanti e muoio e
sono kaki però spero che non mi capiti
avanti sarebbe stato fin sulle tasche è
il mio è un disturbo ossessivo
compulsivo sta roba da natal che io devo
guardare assolutamente devo finirle le
tasche anche se effettivamente sarebbe
più utile andare in giro a vedere chi
ammazza all'inizio della partita
sinceramente però io le devo fare più
forte di me la faccio quindi faccio
questa in armi né poi corni security
ragazzi che ho finito le tasche è quasi
sicuramente step perché per una roba del
genere o e step sia opere step sono una
in caffetteria altro pure non attraverso
canali geisha quindi qua c'è e va vicino
ok c'è una caffetteria di strada è la
seconda volta che stesso passo sul
canale e demoni foto
secondo mandato
ma cosa ci ha trovato subito col
immediata no non era stesso raga io vi
giuro ha convinto a convintissimo che
fosse stelle addio 93 nato sono i nostri
ora che questo in emergency che nessuno
riesco a chiamarlo abbiamo fatto la cosa
ma scusami anche prima ma se non viste
che ci posso fare magari ci stava
crollando e non è una cosa è una cosa
automatica se è morto nessuno che accusi
non era lui secondo me sì tu è
automatico per poi magari ci sbagliamo
però non posso non votarti impossibile
infatti le lotte di catania salvatore
porta dai bella col bel goal
vediamo visto che sono rimasto senza che
le tasche da fare di dare un'occhiata in
giro
secondo me i ragazzi potrebbe anche
essere charlie ma per un semplice motivo
perché charlie e molto si sta in genere
ogni tanto parla quando non parla per un
po non lo so ragazzi non lo so perché
anche fere prima non lo so raga c'è
qualcosa che non sta funzionando in
tutto ciò quindi vediamo
rimango insegnamento in palla fair e va
in admin ok quindi perina admin vediamo
cosa fare per sé non sembra che stia
facendo sembra che stia girando a caso
[Musica]
il report passion è stato per premere ma
questa stanza emergency aspetti di
trovarmi scusa che stava rincorrendo
qualcosa perché io odio il sospetto che
mi dovete pensare una donna partirà per
aver de marco la rai non so chi sia
completamente annebbiato il cervello non
ho idea di chi sia non ho idea di chi
sia di chi possa essere io rimango qua
perché mica go che possa uscire qualcuno
rimango qua aspetto un attimo e in
emergency votiamo io voterò cesca sono
già qua monterice scala cesca e molto
più come eccola eccola mille volte no
tranquillo ragazzi ho bisogno e rim o
bisogno di chiedere scusa nate perché io
ho trovato due volte nella vita e tutti
e due le volte ci è passato nato per
impostare tutte le volte ha camminato di
troppo detto davvero si cadaveri
quando sento una pentola e se basta
anche lui a caso va bene per usura
ragazzi miei questo era il video di amon
gazzi oggi peccato perché se avessi
fatto quella killing che non mi fossi
fatto sgamare all'ultimo secondo ogni
tanto mi pio malissimo
ci vediamo fosse bisogno i ragazzi voi
scrivete anche noi come sempre e fatemi
sapere con i commenti se volete altri
tipi di mini giochi fatti sono un gatto
che sono me sono molto divertenti
comunque noi ci vediamo l'anno prossimo
i ragazzi
[Musica]